they are my family and me and Kelsey
been knowing each other for a long time
since like 2013 he got in my mom
what's up GQ is Megan stayin okay ate a
hot girl coach and these are my
essentials so my phone is definitely an
item I cannot live without I mean how am
I gonna talk to y'all about how my
father and I need to be call me up y'all
need to be calling me I can't live
without you I actually have like four
phones but this is the main one and my
other ones or actually my other three
are dead all the time I don't I don't
even know where they are right now
honestly like the other phones I don't
even know the phone numbers - I've
literally had my number since maybe the
sixth grade so everybody calls this one
all the time
these are jalapeno kettle chips and
they're not just regular jalapeno chips
they're our kettle brand jalapeno chips
and these are legit the best-tasting
chips that I've ever had in my life I
literally asked for a bag of these chips
all the time so all my hotel rooms are
like filled up with in here like all my
rooms backstage or like full of kettle
chips they just burn like you know when
you eating a bag of hot cheetos and you
got like all the fires like little
crumbs at the end that's how I feel
about this like I will literally lick
all ten of my fingers forget all the
flavor I've chosen from these two
I definitely cannot live without my
Beach I have at least three pairs of
these I write everywhere I go so I'm
literally just all day long with my
beats on my head and the seekers are
just like super high quality feel like
I'm in the studio I'm not the girl that
likes air pods because I will lose them
and they will fall out and so these are
big enough I can find them
can't lose these but yeah I like super
love these cuz
oh they're stupid loud I listen to my
music really high so I gotta have my
beats actually sometimes I'll write
before I get a beat so a lot of the
times when I get the hitch they're in
them nine times out of ten I probably I
knew what I was gonna say I was just
going to put a perfect beat to fit my
list here but a lot of the times when I
do get instrumentals I'm like no this is
bringing this type of energy out of me
and so then I start right today then
when I hear a beat that I really like
from right into it every day all day I'm
listening to it at any time I'm
listening to it at the moment
[Music]
my next item is my lip gloss clear lip
gloss at dad like it's like the perfect
topcoat for everything and I really like
this one my Revlon because I don't know
it's just super thick and I really like
pink gloss
I need gloss that's gonna stay on my
lips through eight bags of chips
I need glosses gonna stay on my lids all
day
but this is like just the perfect top
coat and I literally hate to my lips to
be dry any time you see me my lives
gonna be looking real juicy real classy
that's why I need the next thing I'm
definitely can be on this earth without
waste water it's really my favorite
thing wanna make you feel good why to
make you smell bad water make it taste
good
water is just good for your body so I
just feel like I always gotta have it
I'm always performing I'm always running
around you know what you want to go you
just got to make sure you stay hydrated
last year I don't feel like I was
drinking enough water and like when you
don't drink a lot of water it could
really mess with your skin so ever since
that I've been might improving with how
much water I feel like I've been going
with it so yeah got to get that water
[Music]
hello the beautiful thing that I cannot
live without is my food for for he
worries say huh
he was a gift and you know he's just
been my little blip everything he's
gonna be turning one next month I'm just
a problem with it I literally I take for
every where like that there's not a
place that you will see me without Bohr
and everybody knows unisport goes
everywhere they need to start giving him
his own dressing room at this point
because he's famous like people people
don't even run up on me they run up on
four that's like oh my god Cory worry
mom I get lost in the stock
I literally begin my day watching every
day and I end my day watching anime when
I'm doing my makeup
I'll have it playing in the background
and then before I go to sleep at night
like what I fall asleep to right now I'm
like watching this one called High
School of the Dead and it's super cool I
just got done watching an assassination
classroom not too long ago I really like
Soul Eater boot Exorcist that's what I
have on my nails right now shoutout to
my new girl Coco I really like I love
love love my hero academia everybody
knows that I'm talking about you Tina I
really love Hunter x Hunter I really
love attack on Titan I'm just I cannot
live without music it's just like anime
like I literally wake up to it I go to
sleep to it but music is just something
that's very consistent in my life like
all the time I'm either rapping or
listening to somebody else right it's
always been a big part of my life and I
definitely cannot see myself surviving
without music
recognized by partynextdoor yes I'm a
huge part next-door fan earlier I was
probably listening to some Dom Kennedy
I love Dom Kennedy and I'm always
listening like UGK emcees my favorite
rapper I always listened to be yes
because Tony snows can see so I am the
female pimp see so it's only right that
I use my I absolutely positively cannot
live without these people like I would
not be able to carry out my day if I did
have Kelsie if I didn't have Caitlyn
[ __ ] hell for if I didn't have T
fares all right now if I didn't have AJ
they just definitely get me together
from head to toe and just as crazy as I
am
that's just how crazy they are if they
not worse they're like my family they
are my family and me aquel should be
known each other for a long time since
2013
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
okay we know yeah so I can't live
without them and I'm just very lucky and
blessed that I have these are wonderful
human beings in my life
so you have thanks so much for checking
on my stitches until next time